digamos que tenemos un cierto número a y
le queremos sumar un número b y que la
suma es igual a c nos dijeron que hay b
son números irracionales irracionales
con base en la información que les he
dado de que hay b son irracionales el
resultado de la suma se va a ser un
número racional o irracional los invito
a pausar el vídeo y tratan de responder
esto por ustedes mismos
supongo que probablemente tuvieron un
poco de dificultad con esto porque en
realidad no lo sabemos
depende de qué números y racionales son
ahí ve a qué me refiero con esto bueno
puede escoger los números irracionales
cuya suma sea racional que quiero decir
bueno qué pasa si a es igual a pi y b es
igual a 1 - pi ahora estos dos números
son irracionales pi es irracional y 1 -
pi cualquiera que sea el valor de esto
también es irracional pero si sumamos
estos números si sumamos más uno menos
pi
bueno esto va a ser igual a 1 que
claramente es un número racional de modo
que pudimos encontrar un escenario en el
que sumamos dos números irracionales y
el resultado de la suma es un número
racional en general podrías hacer este
truco con cualquier número irracional en
lugar de pi podrías tener la raíz
cuadrada de dos más uno menos la raíz
cuadrada de dos estos dos lo que tenemos
en anaranjado es un número irracional y
lo que tenemos en azul también es un
número irracional pero la suma base
racional podrías hacer esto y en lugar
de tener 1 - podrías tener un medio
menos podrías hacer esto con muchas
combinaciones diferentes de manera que
podrías concluir que la suma es un
número racional pero podría sumar
fácilmente dos números irracionales y
terminar con un número irracional por
ejemplo si a es igual a pi y b es igual
a pi bueno entonces la suma va a ser
igual a 2 pi lo que sigue siendo
irracional o si sumas pi más la raíz
cuadrada de 2
sigue siendo irracional de hecho
matemáticamente esto lo expresaría como
más la raíz cuadrada de 2 esto que
tenemos aquí es un número que sigue
siendo irracional entonces lo importante
es que si tienes la suma de dos números
irracionales y no te dicen nada más no
te dicen cuáles son los números
irracionales específicos no sabes si la
suma va a ser racional o irracional
ahora pensemos en el producto en un
ejercicio similar
digamos que a por b es igual a c a por b
es igual a c una vez más digamos que
alguien te dice que los dos números a y
b son irracionales pausa en el vídeo y
traten de pensar si se debería ser
racional y racional haciendo lo podemos
saber traten de hacer algunos ejemplos
como los que hicimos antes cuando
revisamos la suma muy bien pensemos en
esto vamos a ver si podemos construir
ejemplos en los que se resulta ser un
racional bueno como puedes ver me gusta
usar pi es mi número irracional favorito
si a es igual a 1 sobre pi y b es igual
bueno cuál es el resultado de esta
multiplicación el producto de uno sobre
pi por ti va a ser igual a pi sobre
piqué es igual a uno aquí tenemos una
situación en la que el producto de dos
números irracionales es igual a un
número racional pero qué pasa si voy a
multiplicar uno sobre la raíz cuadrada
de dos por la raíz cuadrada de dos en
general podrías hacer esto con muchos
números irracionales esto va a ser igual
a uno que pasa si en lugar de esto tengo
pi por pi pi por ti bueno esto lo
podrías escribir como pi cuadrada y pi
cuadrada sigue siendo irracional esto es
un número irracional no siempre se da el
caso de que si multiplicas el mismo
número irracional si elevado al cuadrado
un número irracional siempre será
irracional por ejemplo si tengo la raíz
cuadrada de 22 veces pienso que puedes
ver hacia dónde vamos raíz cuadrada de 2
por raíz cuadrada de 2
estoy haciendo el producto de los
números irracionales de hecho es el
mismo número irracional la raíz cuadrada
de 2 por la raíz cuadrada de 2 bueno va
a ser igual a 2 lo que claramente es un
número racional una vez más si estás
obteniendo el producto de dos números
irracionales no puedes saber si el
producto va a ser igual a un número
racional o irracional a menos que
alguien te diga cuáles son los números
específicos si estás haciendo la
multiplicación o la suma de números
irracionales para saber si el resultado
es un número racional o irracional
necesitas conocer los números que estás
usando hasta el próximo vídeo